das kleine dorf kloster veßra im süden
thüringens wälder bäche fachwerkhäuser
vielleicht eine der schönsten regionen
deutschlands
und doch hat sie ein braunes problem
das problem heißt tommy frenck der
bekannteste neo nazi deutschlands
passender länger auf seinen hals hat er
stolz das wort rem tätowiert arisch und
jetzt will er auch noch bürgermeister
werden bild -chef reporterin antonia
jamin trifft ihn sie ist jüdin geboren
in deutschland aufgewachsen in israel
die juden zu viel macht in gewissen
einfluss kreisen haben sie schon viele
einflüsse die medien beispiele sind ja
für viele von ihnen viele jüdische leute
sitzen grabner finanzwelt das ist immer
so was dann auch natürlich negative
schlagzeilen macht und tommy franks
freunde sind nicht anders sie wissen das
bild -chef reporterin antonia amin jüdin
ist und nehmen trotzdem oder gerade
deshalb kein blatt vor den mund
keine juden keine ausländer so sehen es
die freunde von tommy frenck und
natürlich werden sie für den neonazi
stimmen wenn er am 12 juni für das amt
des bürgermeisters kandidiert er war
damals über den 5